In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for May 2, on which we commemorate the recovery of
the relics of our Holy Father, Athanasius the Great.
On the second of the month we celebrate the finding of the relics of our Holy Father among
the saints, Athanasius the Great, Archbishop of Alexandria.
This is, in fact, the day of His departure from this world.
His precious relics were transferred from Constantinople at an unknown date and were venerated
in St. Sophia's.
It seems that they were then taken to Venice in 1454 after the fall of Constantinople.
See His life on the day of His principal commemoration, the 18th of January.
Our Father, Athanasius, pillar of orthodoxy and light of the universe, was born in 275,
just before the outbreak of Diocletian's persecution, to Pius' right-believing parents in Alexandria.
People of the most diverse origins rubbed shoulders in that cosmopolitan city, where cults
and beliefs of all kinds jostled with one another, but, from His childhood, nothing but
the things of God and of the church held any saver for Athanasius.
One day, Bishop Alexander watched him and his companions at play on the beach, going
through the rites and ceremonies of the church.
He was amazed at their deep seriousness and seeing Athanasius as Bishop proceeding to
the baptism of the children who had not yet received holy illumination, the Bishop declared
it to be a true baptism and took the young boy under His protection.
As a student, Athanasius' main interest was given not to secular subjects, but rather
to weaving the garment of the Holy Virtues by silent meditation on the old and new testaments.
He withdrew for some time to the desert, to be with Saint Antony, of whom he was the
life-long disciple, and, on returning to Alexandria, he was ordained deacon and began his theological
and pastoral labors.
It was then that he composed his first two works, the treatises against the pagans and on the
incarnation of the Word.
After condemning the pagan philosophies and beliefs for their absurdity, he shows in
these works that the Word of the Father is not only creator of the world, his wisdom and
his providence, but that he has also made himself saviour of fallen mankind, subject to corruption.
The Word has become man in order that we might become God.
Who are union with Christ, which truly become partakers of the divine nature?
For he is not a simple creature, but he is word of the Father by nature, the only Son of
God and God, become man in order to make us adoptive sons of the Father.
This absolute conviction was soon to become a driving force of the Saint's life and of
his contests.
As the unyielding defender of the dogma of the divinity of the Word and of the trinitarian
faith, he was, by the same token, preacher of Christian holiness and of the possibility
of our divinization.
At this time, Arius, a priest of Alexandria who loved controversy and set more store on
human reason than on faith in approaching the mysteries of God, began to so discord among
the people by teaching that the Word of God is not eternal, but that he has been created
in time and consequently can be called Son of God only in a metaphorical sense.
Driven from Alexandria, Arius fled to Caesarea and soon spread such confusion throughout the
empire that Constantine the Great decided to convoke a council of the whole church at
Nicaea in 325 in order to issue a clear declaration of the divinity of the Word.
Saint Athanasius went thither with the aged Archbishop Alexander and his action as an advocate
in defense of the truth was so decisive that it won him the admiration of the Orthodox
and the unbridled hatred of the heretics.
His whole life from then on would be identified with the defense and proclamation of the
full consubstantiality, Omoucius, of the Word and of the Father.
The name of Athanasius was to become synonymous with the Nicene and Orthodox faith.
On the death of Saint Alexander, the people of Alexandria were unanimous in their choice
of the ardent Athanasius to succeed him on the throne of Saint Mark.
His first task was to reestablish unity and good order in his immense diocese which was
driven not only by the partisans of the Aryan heresy but also by the schismatic militians
and by the decay of morals and a ecclesiastical discipline.
He spent several years traveling all over Egypt as far as the borders of Ethiopia, preaching
the gospel and ordaining bishops, and he thus won the love of the people who ever after
regarded him as their father.
He also visited the countless monasteries even as far as the Thebeid Desert and stayed for
a while at the tabanises in the great monastic congregation of Saint Pachomius, whom he ordained
to the priesthood.
But during his absence, the militians had put about all sorts of calumnes, and on his return
to Alexandria, Athanasius was accused of having been irregularly ordained, of making exorbitant
financial demands on his diocese, of resorting to violence of all kinds against his opponents
in particular of having overturned and trampled on the chalice of a militian priest, and finally
of having given financial support to a conspiracy against the emperor.
The archbishop therefore made his way to the imperial court at Nicomedia, where he had no
difficulty improving his innocence.
But when he returned to Alexandria, they accused him of having contrived the murder of
Arsinius, the militian bishop of Ipsala, and of using his severed hand for purposes
of witchcraft.
Athanasius had Arsinius brought from the monastery where he was hiding and brilliantly demonstrated
his own innocence at the trial by presenting his alleged victim, safe and sound.
Meanwhile, Arius, in exile since the Council of Nicaea, had managed to win the emperor's
favor, thanks to his friend Eusebius of Nicomedia, an astute and deceitful courteer.
He was therefore restored to his position in Alexandria and disseminated his teaching among
the people by means of songs and catchwords.
However, Athanasius stood firm and utterly refused to receive the heretic into his communion.
In 335, during the celebrations marking the 13th year of his reign, Constantine once again
summoned a council to resolve the theological turmoil.
But the council which gathered at Tyre in Palestine had been chosen for the most part from
among the most bitter opponents of Athanasius.
So when he appeared, accompanied by 49 other Egyptian bishops, all his companions were
refused entry, and the field was left free for the militians to make their lying accusations
against the isolated figure of Athanasius, of which the most serious allegation was the
claim that he had held up the delivery of wheat, essential to the food supply of Constantinople.
He even produced a woman who claimed to have been violated by him.
Since she had, in fact, never set eyes on Athanasius, he asked one of his friends to go forward
in his stead, and the woman, forthwith, professed to recognize him as her assailant, making the
fraud plain for all to see.
The crowd outside maliciously stirred up, hurried Eusebius at him as a sorcerer, a beast,
and unworthy of office.
It was clear that his enemies were determined to discredit him at any price.
Taking the wisest course, Athanasius slipped away in secret to Constantinople where he presented
his demand for justice to the Emperor Constantine.
But despite letters from St. Antony to the Emperor and the support of the people of Alexandria,
the Holy Bishop was exiled to Augusta Treverorum, the chief city of Gaul.
Areas was officially re-established in the church and the Emperor, under the influence
of Eusebius, ordered the Archbishop of Constantinople to concelebrate with the heretic.
However, just before the service, divine justice struck the impious wretch who died ignominiously
from the falling away of his bowels in a latrine.
On the death of Constantine a little more than two years later, his son, Constantine II,
recalled Athanasius from exile, and the saint returned to Alexandria by way of Caesarea
in Cappadocia and Antioch in order to confirm the faith in those regions.
His entry in Alexandria on the 23rd of November, 337, was greeted with jubilation by the people
and clergy.
But Eusebius of Nicomedia and the Aryans did not regard themselves as beaten.
They at once resorted to slander and declared that the restoration of Athanasius was irregular.
A council of confessors of the faith gathered in Alexandria in 338 and assured the saint
of the unanimous support of the entire episcopate of Egypt.
The saint Antony himself decided to travel from his remote desert to the capital in order
to support the bishop through the witness of his word and miracles.
His enemies assembled their own council at Antioch and attempted to intrude a certain Gregory
of Cappadocia into the sea of Alexandria by laying siege to the churches of the city one
by one and taking them away from the orthodox.
The whole city, being given over to riot and bloodshed, Athanasius decided to withdraw
for a time less worse befall and, having exhorted his clergy to stay united against the intruder,
he sought refuge in Rome.
Pope Julius gave him a warm welcome and full support, not simply as to an exiled bishop but
as to one who had become the champion of orthodoxy.
He assembled a council which declared Athanasius to be the only legitimate bishop of Alexandria
and recognized his innocence of all the absurd accusations of his enemies.
Saint Athanasius found other confessors in exile at Rome, including Saint Paul of Constantinople.
He kept in contact with Alexandria by letters in which he directed the affairs of his diocese.
He also contributed greatly to the rise of monasticism in the West by making known the manner of life
of Saint Antony and the Egyptian ascetics.
In 343, the co-emperors Constantius in the West and Constance in the East decided to gather
a great council at Sardica, Sofia in order to resolve the question of the sea of Alexandria
and to agree on a confession of faith.
The bishops of the East, while rejecting the person of Areas, jibbed at the term consubstantial
Homoesios.
Although they would not profess the Son of God as having been created, neither would they proclaim
his complete identity of nature with the Father.
The nub of their opposition to the faith of the Council of Nicae lay in fact in their rejection
of the person of Athanasius.
Since they had demanded, as a precondition of their attending the Council, that the bishop
of Alexandria be excluded from it.
They left that city in uproar, and thereby brought about a schism between the East and the West.
The Eastern Emperor Constance fell in with Aryanism.
He prevented the return of the exiles, confirmed Gregory in the sea of Alexandria, persecuted
the Orthodox, and brought in a reign of terror throughout the empire.
After the death of Gregory of Cappadocia, Constance made several offers to St. Athanasius,
who was then living at Aqualia, a restoration to his sea.
In the end, urged by Constantius, the Pope, and leading courtiers, the Saint agreed to
return to Egypt.
He traveled by way of Antioch, where the Emperor assured him of his support and esteem, Cessaria
and Jerusalem.
Returning to Alexandria once more on the 21st of October in 346, after an exile of more
than six years, he was welcomed by a huge concourse of people, flowing like a river of
gold from every corner of Egypt, and greeting him with branches of foliage, songs and dances,
as if it were Christ entering Jerusalem.
With Athanasius, it was indeed Christ who was present in his church, restored in peace.
For the next 12 years, the Holy Bishop was able to devote himself to his spiritual flock,
to the development of monasticism, and to the sending of missionaries to newly converted
countries, such as St. Frumentius to Ethiopia.
This victory of Orthodoxy was unfortunately short-lived.
Constance became sole emperor in 353, and once again succumbed to the influence of the Arians,
who relaunched their attacks on the Nicene faith and the person of Athanasius with increased
virulence.
The Archbishop was condemned at the bidding of the Emperor, who with threats of exile even
obliged the Western bishops, hitherto faithful advocates of Orthodoxy, to confirm the deposition
of the saint at Milan in 355.
When Pope Liberius and the venerable Hosea of Cordova, who was almost a hundred years
old, protested, they were exiled without mercy, as well as the great St. Hilary.
It only remained to affect the expulsion of Athanasius, who was protected by all the people
of Alexandria.
On the night of the 8th of February, 356, the Duke's Serianos, at the head of more than
5,000 soldiers, surrounded the Church of St. Theonus, where the Christians had assembled
altogether to keep a vigil.
Athanasius remained imperturbable amid the shouting and commotion, seated in his chair, surrounded
by the seried ranks of his faithful, who were ready to die in order to protect their pastor.
In the end, his friends made him leave the Church and persuaded him to flee to the desert.
Rioting soon broke out all over the city against the authorities.
Men, women and children were massacred by the soldiers.
Consecrated virgins were violated and churches pillaged.
Orders were given for the arrest of Athanasius as a fomenture of sedition and for the punishment
of anyone who sheltered him.
As a wanted man, he often had to change his abode, and he found the firmest support
and most attentive hospitality among the monks.
He lived as a fugitive for six years, 356-362, upholding the true faith by a large number
of polemic works and in cyclicals and letters to the bishops of the whole world.
George of Cappadocia, the violent and avaricious man now occupying the Episcopal throne of Alexandria,
did not scruple to put all Egypt to fire and soared in order to subdue the Orthodox.
He exiled bishops, condemned to the minds all who were in communion with Athanasius, for bad
gatherings of the faithful and those who would not yield, he had flayed or burnt to death.
After a year of such cruelties, the people of Alexandria rose up and forced him to flee
in 358.
The situation of the church was now more perilous than ever.
All the great voices which could have been raised on behalf of Orthodoxy and against the intrusion
of the emperor in the affairs of the church had been reduced to silence.
Episcopal seas everywhere were either vacant or occupied by heretics.
And to the emperor's favor the Aryans grew bolder and attempted to impose more extreme
statements of faith, completely denying the divinity of the sun and any resemblance of
him to the Father, in the case of Iatius and Onomius.
The bishops of the east, moderate for the most part and opposed to the term homoosius, only
because of the confusion of the divine persons which could result from its use, accepted
the modification proposed by Basil of Ankara and declared the sun to be of like substance
on moeusius with the Father.
They managed to win Constance to this doctrine and persuaded him to condemn the extreme Aryans
and to recall Pope Liberius from exile.
St. Athanasius and St. Hilary of Portia saw this doctrinal pliancy as offering the chance
of conciliation.
Two councils were held at Sermium for the West and at Sallusia for the East in 359, with
the purpose of agreeing a statement of faith which would be able to satisfy the Nicene Orthodox
and the homoosians.
However, at the Council of Constantinople in the following year the capricious emperor had
Aryan doctrine proclaimed under cover of a vague and treacherous formula, Homeanism which
was imposed by force throughout the empire.
St. Meletius of Antioch and all the leading Orthodox were sent into exile.
Heresy was triumphant everywhere.
The whole earth was lamenting, amazed to find itself Aryan, wrote St. Jerome.
But the Lord kept watch over His church, and He calmed the storm at the moment when shipwreck
seemed inevitable.
In 360, Julian the Apostate seized power and proclaimed toleration of all religions.
The Nices was then able to come out of the desert and return to Alexandria where he summoned
a council which was attended by all confessors of the faith who had been scattered for so
many years.
This gathering was the occasion of the definition of the divinity of the Holy Spirit, which
the heretics were now beginning to call into question.
But the time of toleration was short.
The Emperor soon showed his true colors and began a furious persecution in the hope of
re-establishing paganism.
Advised by his magi and diviners, he sent troops to assassinate Athanasius, the champion
of the true faith.
Protected by the grace of God, the saint once again succeeded in escaping from a church surrounded
by soldiers.
When he took a boat up the Nile towards the Thabad, with the Emperor's men in hot pursuit,
their vessel was soon inside of the bishops' boat, whereupon Athanasius ordered the astonished
captain to turn about and go to meet them.
When they came alongside, the soldiers shouted,
How have you seen Athanasius?
Yes, he replied, disguising his voice, make haste, we have just passed him.
They rode on as fast as they could go, while the saint continued his journey by another route.
He stayed in the Thabad for more than a year in the kindly and consoling company of the monks
of Saint Pacomios until the death of the apostate in 363.
As soon as Jovian ascended the throne, he took steps in defense of the Orthodox faith.
He invited Athanasius to Antioch in order to resolve the problems affecting the sea, but
the Emperor's premature death made way for the impious valence, who revived the policy
of Constance, with even greater ferocity.
He had the bishops recalled by Jovian sent back into exile.
To escape the pursuit of the governor, Athanasius went into hiding for four months, in a cemetery
on the outskirts of Alexandria.
The Emperor of Allens eventually ended the persecution and ordered that the great bishops
should be restored to his sea.
Full of joy the people gathered from all quarters, and running in a crowd to the saint's hiding
place, they brought him back in triumph to his church on the 1st of February 366, determined
henceforth to take good care of their pastor, Kam Watme.
After so many great struggles and sufferings, Saint Athanasius was able to spend his last
years peacefully, surrounded by the love of his faithful and admired by the whole world.
He handed on the torch of Orthodoxy to Saint Basil, who continued the great battle for the
definition of the dogma of the Holy Trinity, which was finally won at the 2nd Ecumenical
Council of Constantinople in 381.
Saint Athanasius gave back his great apostolic soul to the Lord on the 2nd of May in the year
373, at the age of 75, with the confidence of one who has fought to the end the good fight
of faith, justice and love.
While the five times he spent more than 16 of the 46 years of his episcopate far away
from his flock, but never for a moment did he fail to be the bishop, namely the supervisor.
The blameless defender of the faith and the living image of Christ, who is the great high priest
of our salvation.
His steadfastness and unflagging energy in questions of dogma never prevented this
soldier of Christ from being the humble and compassionate shepherd of his spiritual flock,
the friend of monks, the father of orphans, the succor of the poor.
Through the indwelling word of God he became all things to all men.
He was immediately honored throughout the church as the equal of the patriarchs, the prophets,
the apostles and the martyrs.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.